Grüß euch, ich bin Oberstabswachtmeister
Schmidthaler Mario, bin seit 2007 beim
Panzerbataillon 14 in der Bergegruppe tätig.
Ichmöchte euch heute unser neues geländegängiges
Schwerlasttransportsystem 70t vorstellen.
Es handelt sich bei der Zugmaschine um eine
Kooperation von MAN und Rheinmetall. Dies ist ein
V8 Common Rail Direkteinspritzer mit 680PS und
einem siebenachsigen Aufleger von der Firma Doll.
Das heißt, wir sind damit in der Lage, insgesamt
70 Tonnen zu laden. Somit beträgt unserehöchstzulässige Gesamtmasse 130 Tonnen
und wir beim Panzerbataillon 14
transportierendamit den Leopard
2A4 Kampfpanzer und den Bergepanzer M88. Jetzt
machen wir eineRunde um das Fahrzeug und ich
erkläre es euch genauer. Im Fahrerhaus befinden sichdrei Sitze, diese sind für den Kraftfahrer,
den Gehilfen und den Fahrzeugkommandanten. Ich
habe hier verschiedene Bedienelemente. Hier das
Bedienelement für den Aufleger. Dies
ermöglicht es mir die Reifendrücke abzulesen,
das Einstellen des Fahrniveaus und
das Ablesen weiterer Informationen.
Die Fernbedienung ermöglicht es mir
unabhängig von der Zugmaschine mitzulenken.
Dann habe ich hier eine zweite Funkfernbedienung.
Mit dieser hat der Fahrzeugkommandant die
Möglichkeit mich in engen Situationen von außenzu
unterstützen. Ich habe zwei Funkgeräte, um immer
eine Verbindung zu meinem Lotsenfahrzeug zu haben,
da es sich um einen Sondertransport handelt.
Hier habe ich noch eine Kamera die sich am
hinteren Teil des Auflegers befindet. Mit dieser habe
ich auch die Möglichkeitumzuschalten,
um auf den Schwanenhalssehen zu
können.
Hier befinden sich die zwei Seilwinden mit jeweils
25 Tonnen Zugkraft. Es handelt
sich dabei um zwei Spielwinden.
Hier geht es weiter mit dem zusätzlichen
Heizmotor, um die Hydraulik ohne
Zugmaschine betreiben zu können.
Dann sind hier verschiedene
Staukästen für den Aufleger.
Hier haben wir die Rampen die beide über
die Hydraulik zu betätigen sind. Darunter
befinden sich die Stützen, da ich abgestützt
sein muss, wenn ich einen Panzer verlade.
Zuletzt haben wir hier noch den
Bedienkasten für die Hydraulik des
Auflegers. Da haben wir noch einige Manometer
für die Lenkkreise, eine Anzeige für die
Drucke, Bar oder Tonnen und das ist in Verbindung
mit dem Heizmotor das Herzstück des Anhängers.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit die Achsen separat
zu lenken und einzuspuren. Die ersten zwei
Achsen sind gelenkt, die dritte Achse ist starr
und die restlichen vier sind auch lenkbar.
So und jetzt werden wir euch zeigen wie
die Verladung praktisch ausschaut und
dafür brauchen wir natürlich
einen Leopard und einen M88.
Hinter mir steht der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2A4
der mit 55 Tonnen das schwerste Waffensystem im
österreichischen Bundesheer ist. Die Hauptwaffe
ist die 120 mm Glattrohrkanone die sekundär
Bewaffnung sind zwei 7,62 mm Maschinengewehre.
Die Besatzung besteht aus vier Personen,
dem Panzerfahrer, dem Ladeschützen, dem
Richtschützen und dem Panzerkommandanten.
Das ist der Bergepanzer M88 welcher beim
österreichischen Bundesheer zum bergen und
abschleppen von schad bzw. festgesessen Fahrzeugen
verwendet wird. Er hat 50 Tonnen Eigengewicht,
vier Mann Besatzung und wird auch zur
Feldinstandsetzung verwendet. Es gibt
jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten wie man einen Panzer
verladen kann. Entweder er fährt aus eigener
Kraft hinauf, oder wie in unserem Fall, wird
er vom Bergepanzer M88 hierher geschleppt
und wird mit den zwei Seilwinden hinauf
gezogen. Dafür müssen wir noch einige
Veränderungen am Tieflader vornehmen,
aber ich würde sagen –legen wir los.
Durch das neue Schwerlasttransportsystem 70
Tonnen hat das Panzerbataillon 14 eine sehr
wichtige logistische Fähigkeit zurückgewonnen die
wir nun einige Jahre zivil auslagern mussten. Mit
dem Schwerlasttransportsystem 70 Tonnen können wir
rasch Kampfpanzer innerhalb Österreichs aber auch
zu internationalen Übungen verlegen. Natürlich
kann auch der Bergepanzer M88 praktisch an jeden
Ort Österreichs verbracht werden und zum Beispiel
bei Zugunglücken rasch vor Ort eingesetzt werden.
Damit haben wir nicht nur den militärischen
Nutzen sondern auch einen weiteren Nutzen
für die Katastrophenhilfe im besonderen Umfang.
Durch das Schwerlasttransportsystem haben wir
auch moderne Lkw-Technik in den Verband bekommen,
und sind damit auch mit unseren deutschen Partnern
wieder auf dem gleichen technischen Niveau.
Dies hilft uns sehr bei den internationalen
Ausbildungs- und Übungsvorhaben, die das
Panzerbataillon 14 laufend durchführt.